(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre o que
é preço viu e qual é a importância
do preço viu em um leilão judicial.
O que é preço viu?
Preço viu é aquele valor muito baixo, aquele
valor desprezível.
E qual é a importância disso em um
leilão judicial?
Um imóvel, ele não pode ser arrematado por
um preço viu.
O preço viu ele pode anular um leilão.
Vamos entender.
Para a gente entender a caracterização de um
preço viu, a gente precisa fazer uma análise
do que o código de preço viu, que
é a lei que traz as disposições dos
leilões judiciais, exceto os leilões judiciais da justiça
do trabalho.
A gente vai ter uma aula específica aqui
para falar sobre isso.
Mas justiça comum e justiça federal aplicam o
código de preço viu para os leilões judiciais.
O código de preço viu que está em
vigência hoje em dia é o código de
preço viu de 2015, mas esse código ele
só começou a valer em 2016, apesar dele
ter sido de 2015.
Foi um prazo de adaptação para os advogados
e juízes poderem estudar esse novo código de
processo viu.
O código de processo viu que a gente
usava até 2015 era o código de processo
viu de 1973.
Esse código de processo viu antigo, ele já
falava que preço viu anulava um leilão, mas
ele não tinha de forma expressa o que
caracterizava o preço viu.
Não existia uma porcentagem do que seria um
preço viu.
Então o que acontecia antigamente?
Vamos estudar um pouco adiante aqui no curso
que depois que você arremata um imóvel em
leilão judicial, vai abrir um prazo para que
alguém possa contestar a validade daquele leilão.
E aqui eu já quero deixar vocês seguros
do que a gente vai falar um pouco
mais à frente.
Nesse prazo, o código de processo viu de
2015, que é o que está valendo hoje
em dia, ele é muito mais pró arrematante.
Caso o executado, que é o proprietário que
está perdendo aquele bem, faça uma alegação falsa
somente com a finalidade de fazer o arrematante
desistir daquela arrematação, ele pode ser multado em
até 20% do valor do bem.
Essa disposição de multa não existia no código
civil passado.
Então o que o executado fazia no código
de processo civil passado era tentar sempre atrasar
aquele leilão, porque ele tentava alegar que tinha
sido por preço viu, tentava alegar algum outro
vício no leilão, para ganhar tempo, para tentar
anular aquele leilão.
Isso hoje em dia ficou bem reduzido.
Os advogados sabem que se eles entrarem com
uma alegação, e essa alegação a gente chama
de meramente protelatória, que a finalidade dela é
só atrasar, que ela não tem nenhum fundamento
legal para ser feita, o cliente dele pode
ser multado em até 20% do valor
de avaliação do bem.
Então os advogados não fazem mais isso.
Essa foi uma técnica usada até esse código
de processo civil entrar em vigência.
Os advogados realmente antes tentavam protelar ao máximo
a desocupação daquele imóvel, tentavam ganhar tempo para
o seu cliente.
Hoje em dia isso não existe, está bem
diminuído.
Então vamos voltar.
Antigamente a lei não falava de forma expressa
o que caracterizava ou não o preço viu,
e falava que o preço viu podia anular
um leilão.
Então isso abriu um leque de possibilidades para
o executado, ou seja, quem estava perdendo aquele
imóvel, tentar anular aquele leilão.
Hoje em dia não existe mais porque a
lei fala claramente o que é preço viu.
A lei fala que o preço viu é
o preço inferior ao estipulado pelo juiz e
constante no edital, e que se o juiz
não falar expressamente qual é o percentual de
desconto que vai ser aplicado naquele imóvel, a
lei fala que vai ser considerado o preço
viu valor que for inferior a 50%
do valor do laudo de avaliação.
Então vamos lá.
A gente falou na aula anterior sobre o
laudo de avaliação.
Falou que em primeira praça o imóvel vai
a leilão pelo valor do laudo de avaliação,
em segunda praça pelo valor concedido de desconto
pelo juiz, e que esse desconto ele vai
ser aplicado sobre o valor encontrado no laudo
de avaliação.
Então, primeira praça, valor do laudo de avaliação.
Segunda praça, desconto concedido pelo juiz, que pode
chegar em até 50% do valor do
laudo de avaliação.
Mas nada impede que num primeiro momento o
juiz fale, não, esse imóvel vai com 20,
25% ou 40% de desconto sobre
o valor da avaliação.
Eu não quero que fique de cara 50
% do valor de desconto.
Então, preço viu nesse caso vai ser considerado
o inferior ao que o juiz estipulou.
Se o juiz estipula que o desconto oferecido
deve ser de 20%, você deve oferecer como
lance mínimo pelo menos 20% do valor
do laudo de avaliação.
E aqui cabe um adendo do que a
gente falou no final da aula anterior sobre
atualização do laudo de avaliação.
A gente falou que entre o laudo de
avaliação e a data do efetivo leilão podem
passar vários meses e até vários anos, e
que se isso acontecer, o juiz ele não
vai determinar que seja feito um novo laudo
de avaliação.
Ele vai pegar aquele valor então que já
existe e mandar passar por uma correção monetária
daquele valor e que esse valor corrigido monetariamente
vai ser aplicado em primeira praça e vai
ser a base para aplicação do desconto em
segunda praça.
E qual é a importância disso para quem
está interessado em arrematar?
Vamos supor que você pegou o caso desse,
que entre o laudo de avaliação e o
efetivo leilão passaram-lhe dois anos e que
o leiloeiro ele não corrigiu aquele valor.
Significa que se o leiloeiro não corrigiu, ele
botou aquele exato valor do laudo de avaliação,
você vai oferecer o seu lance em segunda
praça com desconto sobre aquele valor do laudo
de avaliação e esse seu lance provavelmente vai
ser considerado preço vil, exatamente porque não passou
pela correção monetária.
Então se aquele valor passasse pela correção monetária,
ele seria bem maior.
Então o lance mínimo, ele também seria maior
sobre o valor que você teria ofertado.
Vou mostrar aqui um exemplo para vocês de
como é que isso acontece.
Selecionei aqui um leilão realizado pela Mega Leilões.
Esse leilão já foi encerrado.
A primeira praça dele foi em final de
abril de 2020 e tinha um valor inicial
mínimo de R$ 2.438.000 e
a segunda praça dele realizada em maio de
2020 estava indo com 50% de desconto,
ou seja, o valor mínimo que esse imóvel
poderia ser arrematado em segunda praça era de
R$ 1.219.000. E aí você
se pergunta, mas qual é a finalidade disso?
Você vai olhar aqui o laudo de avaliação.
Olha o valor que o laudo de avaliação
encontrou.
Esse laudo de avaliação, ele avaliou o imóvel
por R$ 1.800.000. Vamos ver
quando esse laudo de avaliação foi realizado.
Foi realizado em 21 de maio de 2014.
Então se o leilão jogasse aqui na primeira
praça R$ 1.800.000, a segunda
praça, o valor mínimo dela seria R$
900.000. Se você arrematasse por R$
900.000, você com certeza iria arrematar por
um preço vil, porque veja, o valor correto
mínimo para a segunda praça nesse caso era
de R$ 1.219.000, que é
o valor do desconto de 50% que
incide sobre o valor da avaliação devidamente corrigido.
E aqui a gente pode observar que entre
o laudo de avaliação e a primeira praça
passaram quase seis anos.
E por quê?
Nesse caso aqui específico foi o que eu
falei pra vocês.
Tentaram acordo, suspenderam o processo, depois o acordo
não foi cumprido, volta com o processo, isso
tudo demanda tempo.
Então desde a data da avaliação até o
efetivo leilão, esse processo aqui demorou quase seis
anos para acontecer o leilão.
E esse valor tinha que ser corrigido.
O leiloeiro nesse caso corrigiu o valor.
Você vê que o leiloeiro não botou aqui
em primeira praça R$ 1.800.000.
Ele já botou aqui em primeira praça R
$ 2.438.000. Mas e se o
leiloeiro não fizesse esse valor?
Você, como interessado em arrematar, você não deve
dar um valor que depois vai ser considerado
preço vil, porque esse leilão vai ser anulado.
E se for anulado, você não vai ter
prejuízo.
Você vai receber o seu valor, que você
pagou a título de arrematação e a título
de comissão do leiloeiro, devidamente corrigido.
Mas não é esse o objetivo.
Quando você participa de um leilão, você quer
o imóvel e não o seu valor de
volta.
Então aqui nesse caso, se o leiloeiro não
tivesse corrigido o valor monetariamente, você correria o
risco de dar um preço vil e esse
leilão poderia ser anulado.
Agora, veja que como o leiloeiro corrigiu o
valor monetariamente, o valor da segunda praça automaticamente
também já está corrigido, porque ele é um
percentual de desconto sobre o valor de primeira
praça.
Se o valor de primeira praça está corrigido,
o valor de segunda praça também está corrigido.
E o valor mínimo que você poderia dar
aqui já é o valor corrigido monetariamente com
a incidência do desconto.
Não haveria risco da pessoa oferecer nesse leilão
especificamente um lance com preço vil, porque o
leiloeiro fez essa correção.
Se o leiloeiro não apresentar essa correção, caber
você é interessado em fazer essa correção.
Como você vai fazer essa correção monetária?
Existe um site que ele é inteiramente grátis
e eu vou explicar aqui pra vocês como
é que esse site funciona.
Esse site é o Doutor Kalk.
Então você deve acessar o site Doutor Kalk,
abrir aqui o site e nessa parte de
cima ele apresenta uma aba de cálculos.
Você vai clicar nessa aba de cálculos e
ele vai apresentar aqui nesse menu, no canto
esquerdo, uma tabela de atualização monetária.
Você vai abrir essa tabela de atualização monetária
e vai realizar a atualização monetária daquele valor.
Veja, vamos colocar aqui um milhão e oitocentos
mil.
A data inicial ali de correção é quando
o laudo foi elaborado.
Aquele laudo foi elaborado em maio de 2014.
E a data final é a data de
quando o leilão aconteceu em primeira praça, 30
de abril de 2020.
Então vamos lá, 30 de abril de 2020.
Você deve selecionar o índice de correção monetária
que vai ser aplicado nessa sua atualização.
E aqui um dado importante, os tribunais eles
geralmente usam índices próprios de correção monetária.
Então cada tribunal vai ter o seu próprio
índice de correção monetária.
Existem vários índices de correção monetária, como IGPM,
taxa de selic, índice acrelado à inflação e
existem os índices elaborados pelos tribunais especificamente.
Esse leilão que eu estou fazendo a atualização
aqui com vocês, ele foi elaborado pelo Tribunal
de Justiça de São Paulo.
O Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo, ele
tem então seu próprio índice de correção monetária.
E sem problema, o site aqui, ele apresenta
vários índices.
Se a gente descer a tela, ele começa
a apresentar índices da Justiça Federal, do Tribunal
de Justiça do Ceará, do Tribunal de Justiça
do Descrito Federal e aqui no final tem
o Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo.
É esse índice que a gente vai escolher,
porque esse leilão foi determinado pelo Tribunal de
Justiça de São Paulo.
A gente vai botar aqui para executar o
cálculo e o site apresenta o valor atualizado
daquele imóvel.
Veja, R$ 2.438.757. Quando a
gente abre aqui o site do leiloeiro, fica
com uma pequena diferença de reais, R$
2.438.383. E sobre essa pequena diferença,
tudo bem, são alguns reais num valor milionário
de um imóvel.
Isso não tem qualquer importância, você pode dar
o seu lance normalmente.
Agora então, fique sempre atento a isso.
Se você encontrar um imóvel que o laudo
de avaliação foi realizado bem antes do valor
da data do leilão, fique atento se o
leiloeiro ele corrigiu monetariamente esse valor, porque às
vezes com o passar dos anos, esse valor
de correção monetária vai ficar muito grande.
Nesse exemplo aqui que eu mostrei para vocês,
a correção monetária é uma diferença de mais
de R$ 600 mil.
Então se você oferecesse um lance mínimo sem
o valor da correção monetária, seu lance com
certeza seria um lance vil, por preço vil
e esse leilão poderia ser anulado.
Nesse caso específico, não seria possível porque o
leiloeiro ele corrigiu o valor, mas fique atento
se o leiloeiro vai ou não corrigir o
valor.
Isso é em seu interesse, é interesse de
quem está participando de um leilão judicial que
aquele leilão não seja anulado por preço vil.
Então fique sempre atento a essa correção monetária
que deve existir da data do laudo de
avaliação até a data do efetivo leilão.